and I'm sorry the world makes sense it
makes sense once again January movies
that suck because January movies are
supposed to suck and there's been a
couple this month I was actually
enjoying it just I felt like the world
wasn't spinning how it's supposed to but
now we're back on track
I saw do little now let's talk about do
little
[Music]
Dolittle so Doolittle is to take on dr.
Doolittle Robert Downey jr. plays dr.
Dolittle dr. Doolittle talks to animals
he lives with animals who's also a
really depressed recluse which I feel
like is the end game to post youtubers
out there we'll all end up there
evangeline including talking animals not
alive but the Queen has fallen ill so
now dr. Dolittle
his animals and now his new apprentice
kind of anyhow they all go on an
adventure adventure that's it's just a
sloppy mess of a movie and a sloppy mess
of an adventure there's a big part of me
that wants to hold back yes everything
I'm saying in this review this is me
holding back because I still know it's
made for kids it was actually a family
in the auditorium they had like seven
children put on a few moments I just
rolled my eyes the kids laughed they
were having a good time it's like this
movie's a quirky weird choppy cartoon in
live-action format and he still sucks
it's not good it doesn't make it good I
suppose I'm just making excuses because
the children were laughing Robert Downey
jr. oh how and why was he in this movie
this is his first post MCU movie he
knows like I'm done I can do anything I
want
this is he's a high he's the biggest
actor on earth right now
this dude can do anything what's he do
Doolittle because why the [ __ ] not what
was the budget of this steak actually
hold on 175 million dollar how much of
the one hundred and seventy five million
dollar budget went to Robert Downey jr.
first of all and at what point in
burning through that budget did they
realize like I think this movie's gonna
suck cause you know they know Michael
Sheen plays the villain he's one of
those mustache twirling villains yeah I
shall win against that Don dastardly
Doolittle I mean he has a goatee not a
moustache she doesn't twirl it nor does
he actually talk like that but that's
the vibe you got what I'm saying he's
one of those just generic surface-level
kind of villains I mean as a mystery
it's boring as a swashbuckling adventure
it's choppy and lazy is it cats bad no
because the animals in this movie we're
actually pretty good for what they have
like the most enjoyment I had in this
movie I'm not gonna lie I was trying to
pinpoint the voices like Ari who voices
that one who voices that one that was a
fun thing for me but that is nothing to
do with the movie this is it's kind of
like a cinematic scavenger hunt at that
point I'm not at a bar playing Q&A I'm
watching a movie and the movie needs to
be good and in the late third act of
their swashbuckling adventure I don't
want to call it the climax
you're about to find out why but how
does it
pappa love dragon gets an enema and I'm
lying to Doolittle's down there just
with his hands up its ass pulling out
armored bits removes the blockage so the
dragon can fart on him alright well
that's the end of our adventure let's go
home good you know what I wasn't gonna
be nice and then I said all that out
loud just now and I'm like yeah whatever
Doolittle's dog [ __ ] we'll all deal will
be fine I still profess if you have
really young children and want to take
them to a movie it's a safe movie that
they will probably giggle and laugh with
and you'll make all the excuses in the
world to take 25 bathroom breaks I feel
like I wasted my time of this review you
know what this is gonna be it's exactly
what you think it's gonna be have you
seen the trailer Doolittle did you think
yourself oh it looks like one of these
it is anyhow so Doolittle have you seen
it why did you think about it since
you're probably not going to what did
you think of bad boys for life whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]